hello freak [ __ ] first of all it's
good to see you you probably know long
time not great haven't you do too I'm
Terrence King of Queens been a long time
and I found out about you know the whole
Scientology I knew you were into it back
then but it was one of those things
where I'd heard about it yeah and then I
met ya I'm like oh pretty [ __ ] normal
for a nun College right well I'm a
larger was the one student I said the
same thing like pretty normal guy Kelly
Preston is pretty normal
yeah normal yes you know it's I guess
you get deeper get to know them really
well and it might get a little weird
yes yeah because the thing is
Scientologists are good people they
really are it's they really as I did
believed that we were doing amazing
things for the world so they go into it
thinking I'm helping myself and I'm
helping others right but then as you
like you said as you get more and more
and by the weight you don't really get
close to Scientologists when you're
assigned out like your mom's when your
non-playing knowledge is correct like
everything that I did and they do is for
the purpose of setting as an example
being a good person being good friend so
to get you in to the oxygen is a purpose
in that like I would never tell when I
was in a non Scientologist my real
problems it would be kind of bad for the
church to ever appear human woe to a non
Scientologist would be setting a bad
example like it would actually be
considered like a transgression if I
told you Joe you know oh yeah I'm
fighting with my mother fighting with my
husband or I would never tell you those
types of things because it would be bad
PR for the church Wow
so that's something that you're taught
correct now you you kind of grew up in
it yes how old were you when you 9 I
think when my money remember pre
Scientology a little bit and you know
what I remember pre Scientology was you
know I had a very Catholic Sicilian
father who you know believed in
punishment believed in not taught like
what did I talk to you
I don't know what you're talking to me
like that kind of guy right like my my
dad says at the head of the table and
then we don't talk back at all or you
know so that is kind of where I knew and
then we were baptized as Catholics
because my mother wasn't really
religious my mother's Jewish she's you
know so she but she didn't have any kind
of religion growing up my father of
course was Catholic so we got baptized
as Catholics and the only time we really
went to church was with our grandma
wanted to visit her and you know in the
city and my dad on holidays so that's
really kind of all I remember pre
Scientology and my mother meeting my
stepdad he was in Scientology and he got
her in as loss like right away right
away yeah so that was like part of the
deal correct yeah and by the way Joe
like we went from like don't talk until
you're spoken to to hey we see you as
spiritual beings we want you to talk to
us we want you to communicate like
you're just you're not you're not
children you're you know spirits in a
little body and so immediately that kind
of indoctrination begins that you're not
a child and so you know as children you
have kids you know they always want to
be grown up so that that really starts
to work this kind of idea that you're an
elitist that your ego becomes kind of
stroked as a kid like you're very
powerful and you returned and you came
back and you found yourself back you
picked your mother because you knew
she'd get into Scientology and you're
very strongly and you're very strong
Nicole to my sister you picked your
mother you know takes your mother a lot
of this reason to find your way back to
Scientology now as a child remember you
you want to be more important than you
are kids are always trying to exercise
their power you know so that speaks to
something inside of you that like oh I'm
bigger than a kid I'm more than a kid
I'm a spiritual being in a little body
and so it sets up that kind of
indoctrination very early on did you
like it because it made you when you
were young it made you feel like okay
now I can express myself better that I
don't feel suppressed yes exactly
because you know again I'm going from a
dad who told me to
shut the F up and walk when I talk to
you and you sit in that chair and you
don't have any thoughts worth listening
to
- you're very much an important being
you're a big being that's a word that's
used a lot those words big beings you're
a big being and so yes you start to feel
very important you start to feel that
you're powerful these are not bad things
and my kids feel but this is the way
cults work and you don't realize that
Joe until you're out
you don't realize any of this was really
going on because I've heard people call
it a cold throughout my 30-plus years
and I was offended by it I was deeply
offended by it and I couldn't even allow
myself to believe that I was in a cult
and so all these epiphanies are only
happening you know after the fact well I
was Washington scholarly documentary
wants on Christianity and they were
referring to it as the cult of
Christianity and it's it's that word is
the correct word really want to just
look at in terms of the actual literal
definition of it yeah but when any it's
automatically got this negative
connotation yes a the word cult people
think you're brainwash you're lost right
there there's a there's a natural
inclination that people have to be
tribal there's a natural inclination
people have to be on a team and we like
it when we're all together yeah you know
I know you're a Scientologist I'm a
Scientologist we're together in this
thing everybody else doesn't get it
right not yet that's a good feeling
right yeah and you're taught that it's
not even just that you think it Joe you
you are taught that you are the elite of
the world
[Music]